what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to be breaking down episode 15 of
attack on time season 4
in which zeke's full backstory was
revealed and grisha's parenting skills
were nowhere to be seen
this episode in particular did raise a
lot of questions such as why erin
seemingly wants to end the aldian race
not to mention why the eager brothers
didn't just make contact in mali so
today i'll be talking about all of that
as well as the other parts that i felt
needed explaining before we begin be
sure to hit that sub button if you
haven't already and also i'd appreciate
if you drop a like because it does help
out the video
okay so episode 15 is called soul
salvation and his purpose was to show us
zeke's true plan
and how his childhood led him to this
point until recent episodes
we believe there were two sides in this
conflict going on with the first side
being mali who want to destroy parodies
and the second side being parodies
itself who wanted to use a partial
rumbling of the earth to protect the
island before marley could launch an
attack
what we now know based on recent
episodes is that there is a third side
in this equation led by zeke
and his end goal is different to both
what marley want and is different to
what paris want as well whereas marley
would like to obliterate the aliens on
parodies with military force
zeke instead wants to ensure that all
eldians never have to suffer again
in his mind being born an aldian is a
curse that only leads to suffering and
it would have been better if they were
never born in the first place
there are many characters who do not
share this opinion but zeke genuinely
believes that he'd be saving eldins from
suffering
if no more were ever born again looking
back into his childhood
it was also pointed out that zeke is a
person who isn't really interested in
war
and we saw that earlier this season when
he regretted having to solve conflicts
in this way
during his life zeke has still
participated in war but similar to aaron
kruger
i'm sure zeke feels like the bad things
he's done were necessary sacrifices
anyway the point i'm making is that when
you combine his desire to save aliens
from suffering
and his desire to avoid war his plan is
therefore to peacefully end the elding
race without conflict
this is where eren comes in as in order
physique's grand plan to happen he needs
his younger brother to do two things
number one is that once they make
contact aaron will be able to use the
founding titan
and with that power he can stop elders
from having the ability to reproduce
meaning the race will slowly die out
over the next 100 years
number two in order to guarantee that
aliens on parodies can peacefully go
extinct like zeke wants
aaron needs to do something to ensure
the island will never be attacked again
he can accomplish that by triggering a
partial rumbling of the earth as its
unparalleled destructive power
would make every nation too afraid to
attack the island as you can see
zeke's overall goal is different from
both the other sides but he's made it
this far
by pretending he was on mali's side then
pretending he was on the side of the
island
when really he had his own motivations
all along however his mission can't be
completed without the founding titan
which is why his predecessor told him to
find a founder he could trust
zeke's royal beast titan is simply a key
that will allow aaron to unlock his
power
but ultimately it is aaron who will
decide what happens next when they spoke
in mali
that's when he felt like aaron was
someone who would fulfill his plan which
is why he started tearing up
you may then be wondering why they
didn't just touch back then and the
truth is there are a couple of good
reasons for this
firstly the fact that zeke had already
been sending his spinal fluid to
parodies for about three years
it shows us that he always intended to
go to the island and seize control
in fact in his original proposal zeke
stated he wanted to live there for the
remainder of his years although that
line of dialogue was skipped over in the
anime
by waiting before they made contact zeke
was able to play both mali and the
military on paradise and ensure his safe
arrival on the island
we know from episode 14 that he and
aaron had agreed a time and place in
which to do the plan once they were on
parodies
and now they're in a much better
position as the aegis are in control
and aaron has support all across the
country secondly given that they already
had a plan in place
there was no reason to deviate from that
especially as aaron had only just gained
zeke's full trust
if they had touched early then aliens
across the globe would have felt their
bodies being tampered with
not to mention that a partial rumbling
of the earth is necessary for zeke's
full plan
but they couldn't just do that out of
nowhere or else many aliens or parodies
would be killed
remember that when you're going to do a
partial rumbling you need to evacuate
the area you're going to be rumbling
because
if you don't then a lot of people are
going to die either by being crushed by
the titans
or by the rocks falling down that's why
shigachino was going to be evacuated by
the military beforehand
so as you can see aaron and zeke just
doing the full plan out of nowhere
it just would have been terrible as a
random side note zeke gave his brother a
baseball during this conversation
and this is the same ball that falco was
asking about in episode 4.
with that explained let's get into
zeke's tragic backstory which caused him
to be the way he is
it starts with grisha and diner taking
their son out of the liberia internment
zone because if eldians get a special
permit
then they are allowed to leave for short
periods zeke seems to be around four
years old at this point
and the reason his parents took him to
this tower was to get a good view of
liberia itself
we can see the eldians in the internment
zone are confined by this large wall
which has very blatant parallels to the
elderly and paradise as well
whereas aaron was caged in due to the
dangerous pure titans outside the walls
zeke was caged in by a society that
despises the aldean race
if you think about it this scene in
particular was really ironic
as this cleaner verbally abused the
yeager family and detested the fact that
eldians were still having children
the irony is that out of all the people
in this interaction zeke would grow up
to agree more with the cleaner than his
own parents which is literally the
opposite of why they took him to this
tower
following on from this the anime flashes
forward to when zeke is a warrior
candidate
and at this point in time all the kids
were competing to inherit the beast
titan
the way he struggled to compete reminded
me of a young rhino but it's funny to
compare the reasons they were struggling
reiner arguably had the most desire to
become a warrior out of anyone but he
lacked the natural talent that was
required to be the best
zika on the other hand was blessed with
royal blood and in theory he should have
been the best candidate out there
but he lacked the drive to actually
become a warrior a young commander
mcgath noted that it was almost like he
didn't want to be there
and the former beast titan seemed to
agree as well this beast titan was tom
sava
and i've already spoken about his full
backstory in a different video that you
might want to check out
from observing zeke on a couple of
occasions tom felt immense sympathy for
the boy
as he could tell from the beginning that
being a warrior is not something he
wanted to do
as a researcher tom thought the concept
of becoming a titan shifter for war was
pointless
and the only reason he got his shifter
was so that he could learn things from
the memories of previous beast titans
he and zeke were therefore similar in
that they lacked the desire to fight for
mali
and by playing catch together they built
a father-son relationship over the years
zeke was lacking a proper father figure
at home because grisham simply used his
son as a tool
to fulfill the plan of the elding
restorationists we saw how zeke's
parents would constantly leave him at
his grandparents house
while they attended their restorationist
meetings and rather than playing with
his son
grisha used all the boy's free time to
study instead one of the worst parts
about this
was that zeke would be studying in
school learning marley's version of
history
then he would be sent to his
grandparents pretty much every night
where he would then learn the same
version of history again
only to then go back home and learn a
different version of that same history
from the perspective of the earlier
restorationists you can imagine that as
a child who doesn't really want to be a
warrior anyway
all of that conflicting information
would be incredibly stressful which is
why you was so excited to maybe read
something else instead
back at training commander mcgath had
been monitoring zeke's lack of progress
for a while
and effectively expelled him due to a
lack of desire
in the commander's words marley would
never give a title to a candidate like
him
but by pure coincidence this was the
same day that zeke first encountered tom
there was a nice bit of foreshadowing
here as salva tells the boy that he'd
make a good pitcher
and in the future zeke's pitching
assault became his main weapon as the
beast titan
i doubt either of them thought this
would be the end result of them playing
catch
but life comes at you fast an important
thing to note is that zeke playing with
someone was such a rarity
that he ran home excitedly to tell his
parents that just gives you some idea of
how his childhood was anything but
normal
and it actually led to one of my
favorite moments of the episode grice
was falco's uncle and a high-ranking
member of the elding restorationist
and he had come to grisha's house to
inform him that zeke was probably not
going to be chosen as a warrior
like i said mcgath told the boy he had
no chance which meant that even aaron
kruger
would not be able to influence the
military's decision you can't help but
feel sorry for zeke in this scene as the
pressure placed on him was unbelievable
imagine hearing that you specifically
have a once in a century chance to save
your race
like that's a lot of expectation for one
child to tolerate and i just think zeke
he was never gonna live up to it this
moment was the perfect chance for
grisham to question
if his son really wants to be a warrior
but the thought never even crossed his
mind
we see later in the episode that zeke
was content to live his life inside the
wars of liberio
which is the polar opposite to his
brother on parodies who felt trapped
within the walls and desperately wanted
freedom
in that way aaron is the child that
grisha thought zeke was going to be
and his mistake was not realizing that
his oldest son just wanted to be a
normal kid
and you know have a real father years
later after zeke had reported his
parents
he would assume he had no more reason to
be a warrior candidate but my assumption
is that he remained with them so he
could keep playing catch with tom
after all it was a thing he enjoyed
doing the most and the only way they'd
get time to play is if he stuck with the
warriors
from his conversation with tom we
learned that the founding titan was once
used by a previous king
to alter the bodies of every alden and
make them immune to a specific disease
this is what triggers zeke to remember
the words of that random marlin cleaner
because if the founding titan can alter
the bodies of eldians then surely you
could also remove their ability to
reproduce
by doing this the world would never have
to live in fear of titans again and
aldeans themselves would no longer have
to suffer
of course this was just a hypothetical
situation that zeke happened to think of
but you can tell he didn't seriously
intend to do anything until he heard
about tom's past
like zeke salva also believed it would
have been better to have never been born
as his malian wife killed herself and
his son once she found out he was an
aldian miner spoilers ahead but as tom
reminisces about his past
you can see there was a sheep plushie
next to him previously when we saw
zeke's past in season 3
he was playing with a monkey plushie and
that's what he became is the beast titan
so the implication of putting this sheet
next to tom is referring to what his
titan is
i know a lot of people to this day think
he had a whale beast titan but no if he
had a whale then trust me this would
have been a world plushie instead
when zeke eventually inherited the titan
from tom the ceremony was held in this
special room that was later used for
porco and the other warrior candidates
something worth pointing out is that
after zeke ate the beast titan he
emerged from the smoke holding sarva's
glasses in his hand
and refers to tom as his father this is
a direct parallel to an eren 8 grisha
as he initially woke up holding his
father's glasses as well
in zeke's case he went on to wear those
glasses pretty much for the rest of his
life up until now
and that was his way of honoring his
adopted father before tom died
he told zeke that he would always be
watching over him which is why later in
the episode
present day zeke said he hoped cassava
was watching moving on during season 2
you'll remember how the beast titan
arrived on paradise island to see what
was going on
whilst in the finale reiner and bertolt
witnessed aaron using the founding titan
here we get a new flashback to after
those events in which reiner informs
zeke of the intel they've gathered
with the knowledge that aaron's father
is a missing doctor called jaeger
he deduced that his father had survived
being sent to the island and the eren
must have been indoctrinated in the same
way that he was
that's why in season 3 he said they were
both victims of grisha because he
assumed his brother was forced to become
an elden restorationist
although as we know that is just not
true another detail is how reina
mentioned that aaron's father left info
in shiganshina
and there's a reason i love this part
specifically obviously reiner and berto
have no idea who aaron's father is as
far as they know he was just a regular
guy who was born on the island
to zeke though he knows from personal
experience that grisham would have left
something relevant to the alien
restorationist
and because he thinks that aaron has
been brainwashed that's why he was so
confident that aaron would return to the
basement soon
next thing to explain about this episode
is aaron apparently betraying the people
of parodies island
because up until now we thought he was
fighting to save them from the outside
world
but now it seems like he's doing the
opposite by helping zeke to end the
aldian race
the question is why would aaron agree to
do something like this when it seems
fundamentally opposed to his nature
and there are two possible answers which
we'll get to in a minute when talking to
his brother
aaron refers to this incident when he
kisses stories hand as back then he
unlocked the full memory of when grisha
killed the royal family his facial
expression indicated he had seen
something super messed up and here he
talks about how he felt the royal
children being squashed like bugs
this is where the conversation takes an
unexpected turn because aaron fully
acknowledges that grisha had to squash
their children
otherwise aaron himself would have been
eaten by the royal family by now
in this moment aaron admits that
grisha's actions allowed him to live
and unlike the royal family he is not
restricted by the vow to announce war
those sound like the words of someone
who agrees with his father's actions yet
in the same breath
erin goes on to say that both he and his
father were wrong his logic is that if
eldings were never born
then they wouldn't have to suffer in the
first place which is the same line of
thinking to both zeke and tom
by saying this he visibly surprises his
brother but also gains his trust
which is necessary if they're going to
make contact as i mentioned there are
only two reasons why aaron would say
what he said
which is that either he does genuinely
believe it or he doesn't and he's just
lying
starting with that first option let's
examine why aaron would actually believe
that it would be better to have never
been born back in the uprising arc
that was the first time that aaron was
told of what his father did and he
showed real remorse for those actions
even going as far as to ask historia to
kill him on top of that
he's also had his fair share of
suffering over the years with of course
the biggest moment
being his mother being eaten by a titan
therefore it is definitely plausible
that aaron could buy into zeke's
ideology
especially as he was already willing to
die for grisha's actions
contrarily he could be lying instead
because zeke's idea to sterilize aliens
is the opposite of freedom
since the beginning aaron has fought for
freedom in many forms first he wanted
the freedom to freely leave the walls
and then once that was accomplished he
wanted parodies to be free of their
enemies from the outside world
if he was to then take away the options
for aliens to reproduce then that is a
forced extermination of their race that
will gradually lead to the end of
society on parodies
this is obviously very different to
eren's usual beliefs so we have to ask
ourselves if he is lying
then what would he gain the answer is
that by gaining his brother's trust
aaron will eventually have access to the
power of the founding titan and as we
know
it is his choice how he wants to use
that power with that said
the episode ends with present day zeke
pulling the trigger on his thunderspear
and blowing both himself and levi
up and also this horse which definitely
did not deserve that we'll see which
characters do or don't survive in the
season finale
but the only thing i really wanted to
say on this was that zeke felt backed
into a corner and would rather risk his
chances of surviving this explosion than
being eaten by a titan like levi
intended
be sure to smash that like button if you
liked the video and i'll see you on
sunday for the last attack on titan
episode review
unless they decide to make a part 2 for
this season by adapting the remaining
manga content
but only time will tell until the next
one peace out